What if I told you there's one simple
rule that could completely revolutionize
your productivity? If it takes less than
five minutes, do it now. Your brain is
carrying dozens of small tasks that are
secretly draining your mental energy.
Most of what's weighing you down,
requires less than 5 minutes to
complete. Each time you finish
something, even something tiny, your
brain releases dopamine. You're
literally programming your brain to
crave productivity. Think about how
often you've spent more energy avoiding
a task than it would take to just do it.
We've all been there, scrolling for 20
minutes to avoid a 3minut task. The
magic happens when this becomes
automatic. After 3 weeks, I was handling
small tasks instantly without thinking
about it. For just one week, commit to
this rule completely. I guarantee you'll
never want to go back to your old
habits. Are you ambitious but too lazy
for complex systems? This is for you.